in one cross test the foundation thought  scp-682 the hard to destroy reptile  would bite off more than it could chew  with scp-807 a deadly plate from the  last chance Diner this plate makes any  food placed on it extra delicious but  also makes them extra unhealthy so  unhealthy that people who eat its food  tend to die of massive heart attacks  they use the plate to transmute two  scp-682 specials a mix of 10 kilograms  of rotten meat and sharpened bone  splinters 10 liters of rancid mayonnaise  1 liter potassium Cyanide and one  kilogram morphine hydrochloride  considered a five-star course for our  pal scp-682 and fed it to the beast at  first it seemed immobile perhaps the  monster had been vested but when  d-classes entered to check the  creature's skin ruptured in several  areas ejecting high pressure Jets of its  own blood in every direction killing  them all the reptile was completely fine  afterward and eagerly ate a third 682  special